[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 63 of
the weekly Google apart from podcast hi
I'm Francis Campo and I'm here with my
colleague mark Mendell hey Mark how are
you doing I'm good thanks for incest how
are you doing pretty good waking up
early for this today yeah you from yeah
turning from Pune in india for go
freaking and going soon to mumbai fun
all right you're better where where in
the world are you where in the world i
am sitting next to my kitchen in my
living room yes I definitely jet-setting
it's fantastic the jet lag between the
couch on the kitchen is crazy indeed so
we have a very very cool episode today
following the saga of episodes about
what you can do with a programming
language on the cloud and today we have
developer problems engineer so one of
the worlds that are part of our relation
our division the developer relations
John Wayne parrot and he's gonna be
talking about Python yeah he's going is
today to talk about Python I think that
kind of just rounds out the set of
languages that we have available and
generally supported on our platform I
guess so yeah we've lived on Ruby Java
go no don't JavaScript we've done okay
yeah we're not yeah yeah we're good HP
yeah next we can go with Haskell nice
i'm down we should totally do that I
know could be fun there's a grp c
library fascicle i'm just saying if this
is your pc lang library for basically
any language that is the whole point all
right so enough of a meandering before
we get into our main content however why
don't we talk about there are a lot of
cool things this week actually there are
a lot of cool things yeah there's way
too many so we actually had to filter
out some of them and we'll let them for
next week but we chose the three Massimo
one's definitely different in our humble
opinion yes so the first to like are all
about hardware so the first time around
we are a google hub platform is the
first cloud provider to offer Intel
skylake chips which is pretty cool the
next generation of Intel Xeon processors
so I'm gonna have to ask because I know
that you are like more into hardware
am cuz video games and stuff sure what
oh wow why is this why is this cool what
is like why kind of use cases do you
think that these kind of processors go
tab with so this is kind of cool i'm
actually just reading about it now but
it is cool because it has certain
implications around floating point
performance and that's really useful for
like genomics research to the rendering
data linux stuff like that so it's
pretty great if you're doing sort of
heavy cpu computation type things this
sort of processor can cut down your sort
of work load time by quite a lot so yeah
I guess that that might help basically
any kind of like heavy simulation then
might not benefit as much as they could
from where a second cool thing of the
week which is GPUs yeah yeah so we have
these black box GPS are now available
for Google Google compute engine and
cloud machine learning currently we have
nvidia gpus that are available in 3 gcp
regions US East Asia East one and Europe
East one as well I believe it eventually
we're going to have both AMD and GPU but
right now in open beta we have nvidia
gpus available that you can connect to
Google compute engine instances so the
cool thing is that you can add that up
to eight GPUs in a single in a single
custom vm which is pretty amazing
especially if you're running things like
tensorflow or basically any other
software that is GPU accelerated if you
add eight GPUs you can see a huge huge
increase in performance so definitely
worth trying yeah definitely a clergy
few so tightly integrated with our
machine learning platform so you're
gonna see some big improvements there
the on top of GC you also have it on
plan machine learning so again all these
things like tensorflow specifically they
benefit a lot from GPUs so if you're
already running something on TC your
club machine learning that you think
that my benefit from it go get the truck
cool so outside of hardware there's
actually a really great blog post that i
would love to highlight especially since
i have some content in it i was going to
say it's a really great blog post that i
partly wrote so
hey so I didn't I didn't write this one
it just links to the one that I wrote
now so if you are coming to next or
possibly actually if you're just going
to end up after next looking at some of
the YouTube videos that are available it
can be a little hard to work out which
sessions that you might want to watch
because there's well there's over 200 so
there's a lot of content so what we've
done is we have a slew of articles that
have been written by developer advocates
such as myself and Franciscan and
teammates of ours all about like which
sessions would you like to go to if you
belong to a particular community such as
if you do a lot of windows development a
lot a ruby if you're a game developer if
you're really into G sweet you know a
nap scripting type stuff there's a lot
of blog posts here that you can take
advantage of to give you sort of a
curated list of exactly which sessions
you really should be going to go see
yeah it is it is pretty cool I know that
there's a bunch of different sessions
that I had no idea they existed because
there's so many of them so definitely
reading these kind of like curated list
of these the kind of things you might
like it's definitely worth it especially
if you're coming and if you're not
coming still you should definitely read
it because all of the sessions are going
to be online later on so it can be a
nice reference material to go and watch
a bunch of talks you can basically
binge-watch cloud next later on yeah
it's totally yeah it's pinched much time
you just you know curl up in a couch
watch a whole bunch of videos there you
go okay so I guess that it's time to go
talk to her friend John Wayne pirate
about Python let's go do that so I'm
very happy to welcome to the podcast to
one of our dear colleagues developer
programs engineer by the name of John
Wayne part hey John Wayne pirate how are
you doing I'm doing alright man how
about yourself very good very very happy
and very excited about getting good to
the podcast finally after we mentioned
your name first time that was actually
almost a year ago it was in febrile 24th
episode 14 where we mentioned one of the
cool things we've built that kind of
attention like platform uncover Nettie's
yeah yeah it was a fun side project yeah
it's been a long time but today you're
here to talk about Python but before we
do that why don't you tell us a little
bit about you and what you do at Google
yeah for sure
um just like you guys I'm in developer
relations but developer programs
engineering doesn't really tell you a
lot about what I do just off the cuff so
I focused more on sort of our developer
experience so like documentation
tutorials sample code and things like
that um and also just kind of like
taking a holistic view of the platform
and making sure that developers who
identify as Python developers feel at
home on Google cloud platform cool so um
I don't do very much Python if any at
all so like why Python like what makes
Python great so I python is one of those
languages that you can you can
absolutely start your your programming
career with Python like it's a great
language for newcomers right because
it's very approachable but at the same
time it's also an insanely powerful
language its general purpose it's used
almost everywhere like this heart it's
hard to find places where you don't see
somebody using Python right and it's
just this is incredible English is so
approachable but at the same time you
can do so much with it and it can really
take you a long way so for me personally
I think python is really appealing
because I came from sort of a C++ like
game development background and like
programming was always like this thing
that I imagined like it's always going
to be difficult right it's never going
to be easy and then when i discovered
python i'm like wow this can be easy you
know like I can actually Express
programs in a way that makes sense and I
don't have to struggle with this all day
long just to do something simple right
so I think there's a lot of Appeal in
Python and I think especially for web
applications and and sort of these sort
of data and analysis applications it's
it's really approachable and easy to use
so so since we're really talking about
like the kind of things you can do with
Python wedding it's a little bit about
the things they can do with Python on
Google cloud platform like what is the
involvement of Google cloud platform
with Python so I mean there's there's
essentially like like is you think of it
like it's two buckets right there's
people who are writing web applications
in Python and of course like Google
cloud platform has multiple hosting
options like you have container engine
compute engine
App Engine and Python works on all of
this so you can run your Python web
application on Google cloud platform
will host it for you and then only other
side of things like all of our services
such as data store storage and newly
spanner you can talk to those using
Python right so you can use our services
with our Python client libraries and
even more than that things like data
flow you can use Python to to program
your data flow pipelines and things like
that so the python is is pretty much
everything that you can do one cloud
platform you can do with python cool um
so now they amount that I know about
Python I know there was like the time
the crystal cracked like the Great
Schism it does so what what version of
Python do we generally support what I
don't even know what the ecosystem
really looks like what's what's the deal
with like is it two versus three is that
is that what's going on there so yeah so
two versus three has been the debate for
many years so three came out several
years ago as I say several it was a long
time ago now when three point O came out
and it was there were a lot of like it
was non-trivial to upgrade a project
from 27 to three and well 26 at the time
to three so a lot of people just stayed
with two because if it's not broke don't
you know don't mess with it you know so
that cost a little bit of trouble and a
lot of libraries you know such as Django
didn't port right away and that made it
a lot harder for people to adopt Python
because not only do they have to change
their application but the libraries that
depend on don't support by FM three now
the story is completely different today
almost every major python package
supports both Python 2 & 3 with the
exception of like maybe one or two and
there's replacements for those and in
general the community is very focused on
Python 3 is the future not the future
it's the present and you know we need to
get there as fast as we can the other
thing that's sort of driving this
adoption of Python 3 is that the Python
you know software foundation is going to
stop supporting Python 2 in 2020 so
they've been given that a doomsday
essentially there's actually a Python
Doomsday Clock you can pull up it gives
you a cat
two twenty20 when we can stop worrying
about Python 2 so it's pretty
interesting stuff so um in terms of you
know sort of where we focus what we as
in Google cloud platform focus you know
we definitely want to support python3
right while not leaving behind the
people who are still using Python 2
because there is still a lot of people
who are using Python 2 so when you look
at our client libraries and you look at
container Engine and compute engine and
App Engine flexible environment Python 3
is is a bit available and supported we
support Python 35 right now with our
container runtime that runs on App
Engine flexible and container engine and
we're about to add 36 very shortly a
pigeon standard is is a special case
it's still on 27 because most the
applications that run on App Engine
standard you know are pretty much using
27 and have no need to update but we are
investing in standard so I would expect
that that might change soon um so either
keep your eyes open eyes peeled they're
so cool so we can use App Engine with
Python to what is the frameworks that
people normally use for these kind of
things I can know that flask I think is
one of them or might be bottle or maybe
both actually I'm very sure can you talk
a little bit of a kind of framework that
we support sure absolutely so um we
don't really make the framework twist
for you in any of our hosting platforms
of course like you know we try to follow
the community and if you look at the
Python community a lot of people when
they think about Python and web they
sort of immediately jump to django
Django is one of the largest open source
projects within the Python community and
has a huge user base and there's lots of
plugins and things like that for Jengo
that make it a lot easier to you like a
lot easier to accomplish task quickly
with Django so we definitely want to
give more attention to django users
because it's just a huge community base
and it's actually something we've been
working on over the last year is making
sure that there's tutorials that fit in
to a lot of what Django users are
looking for that said the Python
community is actually about split about
an even see
between Django and flask right or Django
is more this this larger sort of
framework it's very opinionated it tells
you sort of how to structure your app
and it gives you a lot of batteries
included sort of thing flask is more
like a Spartan minimalist framework I
think it actually started as an April
Fool's joke and people just just sort of
like like the idea of it and it just
kept going from there so I personally am
a flask user and all of our tutorials
for App Engine flexible environment are
written in flask because it's just a lot
easier to write a sample application
with flask there's a lot less code
involved in lawless files and a lower
barrier of entry essentially then trying
to like have a jingle app for every tiny
sample that we write so cool so what
what about other domains other than web
servers like is there any any kind of
support for num num pie related to
Google cloud platform like I could
imagine something like that for i I
don't know data flow or or data lab or
whatever do you know anything about this
yeah so like in with data flow and data
lab you kind of have this access to this
other domain of like you know for data
scientist stuff and in general art
platform will let you use whatever you
want and just kind of get out of your
way so like you know if you're if you're
using our container run timing and
running your data analysis pipelines on
Cooper Nettie's our container runtime
contains everything that you need to
install a numpy out of the box right
that isn't that is to say you just drop
it in your requirements a text file
right which is how you declare
dependencies in Python the way guys um
you just job numpy into your
requirements ID text and then it works
it should just work and so we really
just uh so a lot of Python is like you
know the community has a lot of
opinionated ideas about how to handle
dependencies how to how to deal with
installing things and we just kind of
want to support that and get out of the
way so that we don't we don't block that
sort of thing I think data lab has numpy
and sigh pie pre-installed so you don't
even have to install those on that one I
could be wrong and so don't quote me but
if it's not I know it's pretty it should
be pretty straightforward to install in
data lab data flow I think it's sort of
special purpose built for
you know data processing so I imagine
you wouldn't have any problem using your
normal Python data scientist related
libraries excellent alright cool so that
sounds like we have at least a pretty
decent coverage across Python but are
there any sort of new releases or things
that are being actively worked on that
Python developers can sort of look
forward to yeah I mean so I mentioned
this I sort of you know hinted at this
earlier one of the things that we're
definitely doing is at least in my team
is trying to make sure there's a plenty
of tutorials for Django users right we
definitely want jingo users to fill at
home on Google cloud platform and that
means highlighting products such as
cloud sequel which is our hosted my
sequel solution because Ginga developers
are a lot more familiar with a
relational database management system
than something like data store for
instance so we're focusing a bit on
django over the coming months and things
like that but there's also like there's
always new products being released for
cloud platform like just the other day
we release spanner and of course that
has a Python client library on day one
and you can use spanner from Python if
you want incredibly high scale database
that can do sequel queries so now that
sounds cool now i'm actually just
curious we talked a couple times about
django their particular challenges
around running it on google cloud or
their particular like platforms that
it's better on does it like work better
on like communities and it does App
Engine or something like that yeah i
mean like so i think it just depends on
your workload right so I mean Python I
think if you were if you're doing like
some heavy data processing like clearly
you don't want to use App Engine right
because it's more App Engine snow for
stateless workloads right but if you're
watching web front-ends then App Engine
absolutely makes sense right so I think
it just all comes under your use case I
think all of our platforms are pretty
well suited for running Python I think
it's just a case of what what execution
model is going to best match right uh we
were just doing specifically about
django oj go yeah is there a particular
one that's better for that i would say
App Engine Flex is going to give you the
the absolute best like just out of the
box experience with Django
it's we sort of purpose-built the
developer experience for App Engine
flexible to sort of meet Python
developers where they are right so for
the most part if you have an application
a Python web application that has a
requirements on text file you can drop
in a really simple a PMO and deploy it
to App Engine flexible without any
changes typically you may have to you
may have to change them nicely that's
listening on but that is our goal our
goal is to just be able to take any
django app and just run it on a pinch of
life so i'm assuming that you what you
were saying about the port is you will
need to read the port from an
environment variable something of that
yeah yeah we expose the port environment
variable which is always 8080 that's
that's what go that's why for it go
we're basically working on exactly the
same thing so you can just drop it and
just works which is pretty nice yeah as
I go developer something that I'm
slightly jealous about for App Engine is
you're amazing and DV library Ellen if
you could talk a little bit about it
everybody loves in DB a fun fact it was
actually written by gido van Rossum the
the you know inventor of Python himself
wrote the NDB library so there's a lot
of interesting things in that library
our App Engine standard users absolutely
love it however it's not currently
available outside of App Engine standard
but we know that users love it and we
are definitely looking into bringing
that library and making it available to
use everywhere nice um so we want to
sort of rebase it on top of the the
cloud platform Google Cloud datastore
API instead of the the App Engine
datastore API so that you can use it
wherever so for those that do not know
what NDB ace and actually I don't even
know what ND b stands for could you
could use grab a little bit please sure
for sure so in DB is our RM our object
relational mapping or for App Engine
standard it is named in DB because it
means new DP there was a previous
library for App Engine Center just
called DB that's slightly disappointing
name so come
it's a great name I think so yes it's
just it's a no R M so like if like for
Python developers if you're familiar was
like sequel alchemy or jingoes ORM then
it's somewhat similar to that you sort
of define your models your data models
as classes and then you can you define
the property types on that and then of
course the library handles you know
querying and then serialization and
stuff like that so and it also puts a
memcache him in front of it too oh yeah
that's one of the one of the really cool
features about NDB is that because App
Engine includes a memcache service in DB
does right through caching for all of
your entities so it's pretty neat and it
works works about ninety-five percent of
the time for everybody which is great so
it's one of the difficulties with
porting it outside of App Engine because
you either have to provide some sort of
plug-in interface to be able to add
different caching layers because imagine
if you're running on compute engine you
may not have memcache available to you
you may have read us or something like
that so you want to be able to plug in a
different caching back end or not have a
caching back end if you don't have
anything available so um I'm curious
like is there anything new and exciting
in the Python community that you're
particularly excited about new
frameworks or releases or anything
interesting like that oh man what do I
start um the Python community is always
growing and always evolving with with
the release of 36 we got some really
neat stuff we have this thing called a
sink I oh and in 36 it's no longer sort
of experimental it's actually you know
sort of a supported core part of the
Python standard library so ASA cayo
gives us something similar to goes go
routines in Python mmm so it allows us
to do this really cool you know coaching
asynchronous code and people have done
all sorts of really cool things with
this I've I feel like maybe late last
year I may be getting my timelines wrong
here somebody released a a plug-in for
pythons async io that uses UV loop
underneath the covers which is the I
think the same invented I oh that nodejs
uses so it's blazingly fast
is pretty cool and then somebody else
built a web framework on top of UV loop
called sanic because you have to go fast
so sanic is one of the fastest web
frameworks like ever and it's it's just
super cool stuff so like with with a
sink I owe you can do a lot more with
one process and you can do things like
use different event loops like UV loop
and get insane network performance out
of your Python programs so one of the
things i have on my list to do is
actually write a using sanic that runs
on App Engine flexible so that you know
we can be part of this crazy awesome
movement of a sync stuff going on in
Python nice that sounds that was
actually what I was going to ask you
it's like is that that's these work on a
pension flex so perfect I just I just
haven't like you finished polishing the
the thing so it works out with the Box
on App Engine flexes and there's no
worries there because it just works on
linux and if it works on linux it
probably works in a container and if it
works in the container will run on App
Engine flex so yeah it's exciting stuff
and I just need to publish that sample
because it's super awesome so so Google
is pretty involved with open source
communities last time we had someone
from noche as we're talking about not
jas the nuts what is that the node what
is the name of the community no.js
community not fun denominational there
you go so is there something similar for
the Python community and if so is how is
google you vote with it yes so I mean
we're so involved I don't know if I can
mention everything so Google is one of
the we've been using Python forever at
Google right so in outside of cloud
platform just inside of Google proper we
have a couple of core maintained errs of
a Python we sponsor pike on every year i
think i wouldn't say every i think at
least the last two years we sponsored by
con to my knowledge that's the most
authoritative lee i can speak on that so
respond we sponsor PyCon on typically
you know the Googlers talk there I mean
Google errs are really heavily involved
in the open source community
round python I mean in cloud
specifically I know that we are working
with a lot of open source libraries like
Apache lib cloud to you know help
integrate with Google cloud platform
services and things like that I first
myself I've I've helped out with your
lid 3 which is a very popular Python
open source package for HTTP requests
and like in general we like we try to be
as open as we can which i think is
really positive for the Python community
in my opinion there's there's nothing
more important than open source and I'm
happy that I'm in a spot where i can do
a lot of contributing to open source
cool um you mentioned PyCon is park on
the only event we tend to go to or two
people expect to see Googlers at other
such Python events as well well what's
great about PyCon is that there's not
just one there's like pike on in Canada
there's like PyCon in Japan I think so
there's a bunch of them and we we tend
to be involved in add a few of those I
think I think I are Kali and Luis tends
to do the ones that are over in Japan
and stuff like that so I think we're
really involved in those sort of those
those sort of pike on type events I I
don't know if there's any other huge
icon level events I mean that is really
the the community likes to be sort of
centralized in that way you know this
it's the big one for everybody so we're
super involved in that so I don't know I
don't know I don't know the answer to
that question essentially that's right
that's good that's good we're kind of
running out of time but is there any
other topics or announcements or
whatever that you like to mention before
we finish not at the moment that's
Oliver ever talk if I told you I'd have
to kill you oh oh so something cool is
coming but we don't know what it is you
should kill think you should kill us is
coming the whole audience okay it's a
lot of people but you know whatever okay
well then thank you so much for taking
the time today to talk to us about
Python and let's see when you come back
and tell us what secrets you're hiding
today haha alright looking forward to it
thank you Thanks well thanks again to
John
pirate for such an interesting interview
I personally have written lots of Python
but I have been out of the community for
quite a while so it's always nice to see
what's going on and learning a little
bit what are the plans with like Python
2 versus pass on three the kind of
support we support we have a Google
cloud platform cetera so very cool
interview yeah thanks so much for
joining us John there's a lot of friends
of mine who write Python so I'm sure
they're going to appreciate it so moving
on to our question of the week francisc
you were telling me earlier of a
question that came from one of the
members of your workshop while you were
having your travels in India he was
talking about transactions and being
able to transactionally store data say
in some sort of storage system and then
also being able to send an email such
that say the email failed then you know
the transaction on the on the data
storage or draw back or if the data
storage didn't go through properly and
the email wouldn't go out how can i do
that transactionally in that sort of
situation you know on google cloud yeah
so to be more specific this was on the
context of App Engine like I have this
go web workshop that is basically right
and go up the web applications on App
Engine and we're already using data
store and I mentioned that you can use
the mail ap I'd mail service API from
from App Engine to send emails very
easily and the question was exactly that
so imagine that I want to store
something in the data store after
sending an email or that I want the
email only to be sent when the data
store thing has worked so i want to
basically have set the sending of an
email as part of a transaction this is
something that you cannot really do but
there's actually ways of kind of
mitigating that issue which is one of
the best ways to do it is actually by
using task queues so task is I think
we've talked about a long time ago but
test case is a little thing that allows
you to schedule something to be done
later on at some point so in this case
you could say oh I want to store
something in the datastore and then I
want to schedule sending the email at
some point right now the cool thing is
that storing something
the task you can be done inside of a
transaction instead of a data store
transaction so you can atomically decide
if you should be sending that email or
not according to the success status of a
transaction in datastore which is
actually pretty powerful because then
you can use the same principle to apply
to whatever you want oh so that's cool
so if I am doing something in datastore
with the transaction I can then
transactionally also send off task
queues to fire something in the
background but if any part in that chain
fails then those task queues and that
data storage we'll all roll back
atomically exactly so you'll need to go
and be like oh I'd something that the
task you add that it was like oh let me
get it back there's no need of doing
that you can just use the front section
as you would do in a datastore awesome
so i can send an email or an SMS or just
do something even totally crazy like
compute a whole new thing if I wanted to
or you can lock some metrics or whatever
cool thing you want to do it is quite
simple awesome well thank you so much
for explaining that to as France ask
it's a pleasure wonderful um so i
believe i know you are off to mumbai
next what are you doing there yeah so I
am today while we're recording in pune
but i'm going to Mumbai tomorrow to run
a workshop but by the time this episode
will be out I will be flying over
somewhere in between India and San
Francisco coming back to the United
States and getting ready for cloud next
excellent yeah so pretty much when this
comes out I will be at the game
developers conference like right in the
middle of it but I think yeah I will be
it next as well we're gonna have a
pretty fancy booth set up I think I'm
pretty excited about it we've been talks
about doing daily episodes so hopefully
that all comes together as well I'm I'm
not gonna promise anything just in case
that that that will see because it's
right there it's a big challenge right
there but we're definitely going to be
looking for people to come by the booth
do short interviews come hang out with
us get some t-shirts and stickers we're
really looking forward to seeing people
in next yep and I guess that if you're
gonna come it be
very nice thing to do to warn us and to
get in touch with us yeah the best way
to do this is we have twitter at gcp
podcast we have google plus plus gcp
podcast we have a sub rabbit / r / gcp
podcast we do have a webpage to gcb
podcast calm and an email hello a GSP
podcast and finally we're also on slack
and that is the one that is a mouthful
it's like is hash podcast on the Google
cloud platform community slack that you
can reach at bit ly / gcp dash slack Wow
amazing good job so yeah send us our
questions we got a bunch of questions
during the last week and we'll be using
some of those for our next episode so do
not think that we do not read those
questions we read of every single one of
your emails and we love them so keep
them going yes thank you very much well
France ask thank you for joining me yet
again for another episode thank you Mark
and thank you all for listening see you
all next week
you